hey how's it going bris is past today we
are doing I don't know what to call this
type of videos yet cool and stupid [ __ ]
that I find I wasn't paid to show any of
these items or anything I just thought
it would be a fun video some of them
aren't even weird so [ __ ] it first item
I just thought it was really cool it's
an ocarina it comes with the
instructions on how to play I'm gonna
attempt one but I'm gonna cut in between
I don't want to say it's easy but it's
also not that hard if I can do it it's
really so when I was a kid I was never
allowed to have any weapon of any sort
whatsoever I don't see how that helps
anyone I mean any fake weapons of course
so I got up
but it's it's it's a it's a corkscrew
it's a bottle opener it's not a real
butterfly if you see anyone like hot
chick who needs their bottle open you
can just be like and you're pretty much
guaranteed to get laid to get a weird
look and they will never talk to you
again I don't even know why I buy this
next item is I've been wanting to try
out for so long
I need Edgar's health again come in make
yourself useful you son of a [ __ ] the
next item is for you and yet I hope it
fits good look so badass okay there's no
way in hell it's gonna fit kiss my dog
he's fat and ugly what the [ __ ] is this
oh my god let's get a good look at it
you're not supposed to eat your helmet
wow what a great yeah well you look so
good at gay great purchase yeah why do
you have to say for yourself that is not
a han Solo Zayas well this has been a
failure so far stop stop I buy you gift
you be thankful
thanks underwear I mean the next item
have you ever felt like oh I want to
share my underwear with someone no well
then here's a pair of underwear for two
people no [ __ ] way
oh my god they have four holes your
prayers have been answered and get stop
playing with the dark way to costume
[Music]
this is so awkward
works every time
[Music]
wasn't that amazing Wow
I saved the biggest one for long and
it's a helium ah but it's fun and it's
safe and but the reason I got this one
is because flying sharks didn't tell me
I had to assemble it alright see you in
a bit
I don't think I put this much effort
into anything in life but here it is
[Music]
alright so that was weird [ __ ] I found
on their net that was a lot of fun the
shark Shannon Shannon Shannon fan
fiction can finally be true if you
enjoyed this video please hit that like
button every time you like you save the
fin of a Shannon I hope you enjoyed
watching and as always Bros Stern
awesome
[Music]